and this follows days of fighting which
saw them firing rockets into government
territory the Syrian government has told
its forces which are backed by Russia
that the battle isn't over yet
the rebels also retreated from the town
of morick which is in Hama and it's the
site of a Turkish military observation
post harsh a cone in southern Italy
province is a main population center it
used to be a place where a hundred
thousand Syrians took shelter before the
military escalation began in April towns
nearby in the northern Hama countryside
have fallen to government forces but for
the Syrian government the big prize was
getting control a handshake on that will
give it access to the m5 it's an
important economic highway that crosses
the country's in a hotter has more from
Beirut handshake horn is back under the
control of the Syrian government images
released by pro-regime media show the
town in southern it Lib empty of
residents and fighters rebels withdrew
early on Tuesday after days of fighting
and hundreds of airstrikes its location
gives the Syrian government access to
parts of a vital commercial highway that
connects the northern city of Aleppo to
the capital Damascus and has been a
military objective for months this is a
very important development and the
course of this conflict on idli this is
a the first step in the first stage may
be an effort by the government to regain
control of the territories along the m5
road between Hama and Aleppo I think the
next target will be Martin Norman the
opposition didn't just lose handshake
own rebel fighters had little choice but
to leave towns further south in the
northern Hama countryside they would
have risked being besieged if they
didn't move further north the opposition
was hoping the presence of a Turkish
observation post in the area would stop
the government advance but an attempt by
the Turkish military to reinforce that
position failed when an air strike
launched by a Syrian or Russian warplane
on Monday prevented it from reaching its
destiny
the Syrian government and its allies
have been advancing in the past two
weeks they have now taken more territory
than they did in the first three months
of their military campaign it's not
clear if the rebels who have been
subjected to heavy firepower are
exhausted or if the Army is using better
tactics like concentrating the strikes
close to the front lines and on rebel
supply routes but the relentless
airstrikes and bombardment continued to
force people into displacement in recent
days more than 25,000 are believed to
have moved north closer to the border
with turkey' war monitors and activists
say over 700,000 Syrians are homeless
since the military escalation began in
late April the past few days witnessed
unprecedented bombardment that is why
the people who didn't leave during the
first months of the offensive pack
everything and left most of them
believed their houses would either be
fully destroyed or taken over by the
regime the bombardment of opposition
held towns across southern and lip
continues as the Syrian government
presses on with its offensive there have
been more civilian casualties as rebels
promised to defend what is left of their
last stronghold the battle is not over
senator al Jazeera Beirut